how do you know if your film found the
intended audience or maybe there is no
intended audience
mm hmm maybe it's just whoever likes the
story mean broken ceiling has a female
protagonist it's about a contentious
workplace it's male driven different
things that this person's fighting
against did you have a specific audience
or anybody you want to just anybody who
was interested in a good story to find
it um we did have a specific audience I
don't think that people who are really
into sci-fi or horror would necessarily
like it I needed to find the people that
were into dramas people who you know
worked office jobs day jobs women women
of colors specifically because it's
about a woman of color and a primarily
white male dominated workspace those
were really you know the people the true
core audience for that and when we
started seeing this sort of like
engagement demographics on Instagram
that's what we found
it was interesting though because it was
it was a sort of male/female split like
52% female but very split between males
and females it was great that a female
empowerment story really had you know
legs with male eyes who were interested
in that and you wrote it as well yeah I
did yeah yeah what what prompted you to
write it friend socially from a female
perspective sure sure um the reason that
I needed to tell the broken ceiling
story is because I started writing it
just based on sort of my general
frustrations with with how the world was
working and of course the fact that I
had not made a feature yet you know so I
was very just in general frustrated and
the story is born of that frustration
and you can see that sort of frustration
and all the characters you know all the
characters are sort of doing something
that maybe they wouldn't want
do you know were forced into these roles
that maybe you're not the best for them
so I started writing this a little bit
from my own perspective and then you
know there was a lot of social stuff
that was going on at the time the
Ferguson you know shooting that happened
everything came out of that and it
really sort of hit me you know it made
me sort of open my eyes and go you know
what like I am you know a white male and
perhaps there are things that I didn't
realize you know about ways that I've
been helped out unknowingly just being a
white male you know what benefits have I
had that maybe I wasn't aware of and I
realized that I didn't want to tell that
story because I wanted to give a voice
to you know a character who maybe didn't
have a voice so that's why I decided I
completely revised what I was going for
and I decided that I would do something
that you know at the time I was sort of
afraid to do you know because you know
with how society was and still is it was
sort of like how dare I as a white male
right you know from a perspective of a
black female and a black female story
and that was that was something that
people were like yeah I feel
uncomfortable with that like because you
don't know that experience and truly I
did not know that experience at all you
know who was I to write you know a story
about a black female who had a hard time
moving up you know breaking the glass
ceiling in a corporate environment but
what I did was research I was like I
need to tell the story and I need to
know you know so I did a lot of online
research I read a lot of stories about
you know black women in the work
place women growing up talked to people
you know really did as much research as
I could do and I wrote it you know sort
of on a wing and a prayer and I thought
that it turned out pretty well and then
when we were getting into casting we I
was meeting with the woman who would
eventually become Angela Karen Kendrick
and I remember the first meeting that we
had she had read the script and I was
kind of terrified to meet her because
I'm like you know what are you gonna
think of this story and I will forever
remember what she said but she goes it's
like you told my story my personal story
and that was the highest compliment that
I could get cuz all the research all the
hours put in like it paid off it was
authentic which is super important and
it spoke to her which was the most
important thing and yeah she signed on
and she was fantastic and amazing to
work with and I learned even more you
know through working with her and you
know it it was a wonderful working
relationship and she's gone on to do
amazing things and will very very soon
be an enormous enormous star because she
is so talented so the fact that she
wanted to work on this tiny project and
it felt connected to it was great and
I'm just super grateful that I was able
to get her and the rest of the cast cuz
yeah I was very blessed with the
performances and the actress and that's
something that you know people
definitely call out when they review it
they loved Karen they loved the other
actors you know it's it's it's exciting
to see them you know get that
recognition which they they definitely
deserve did people actually tell you
don't tell this story like you don't
have the right because you don't often
taquinho it or don't go there man like
just just let it be like what what did
they say it was all about the how they
felt uncomfortable
that a white man was telling a black
woman's story you know and and I totally
get that I understand it because I did
not I did not know I didn't grow up with
that you know but the thing that I truly
believe about writers and directors is
that they are able to inhabit different
points of view and different characters
like you have to to be able to write
characters who are different from you
you have to empathize with them you have
to do the research you have to learn
about that like and I think that writers
are fully equipped to be able to you
know write from somebody else's
perspective you know and I think we
should you know I think that anybody
should be able to write anything
provided that they do the research and
they do it authentically that is 100%
the most important thing like you have
to immerse yourself you have to do the
research and you have to make sure that
it is true otherwise otherwise you
shouldn't do it and maybe that's what
they were afraid of that I was just
going to assume or imagine what it would
have been like to be a black woman and
you know a white male dominated industry
but I didn't I did the work because I
had to make it true and and I hope that
that comes out and then were there
people that said thank you for doing
this I know this is not where you live
so to speak in a headspace but yeah
thank you for trying to tell someone
else's story that needs to be told
yeah I mean in the reviews like honestly
the the best reviews that I got were
women of color you know and people of
color reviewing it and going this is
truthful this strikes a chord the fact
that it connected with them is the
highest compliment the highest praise
that I can get and when you said you got
some reviews that weren't favorable was
it of that nature or was its other
things it was actually other things oh I
see Oh which is
which is kind of nice yeah all of the
criticisms were directed at me you know
in terms of like you know maybe the
story could have used this like a lot of
it was a little bit story based about
like well you know because it is so hard
to try to tell you know a story in one
location it is so hard and I don't know
if I hit it out of the park I think I
did a decent job but trying to you know
ring ninety minutes out of one location
is so hard so I did my best but I've
been knocked a little bit for that but
but praised for the directing which I
appreciate and the thing that I
appreciate about those reviews is that
it makes me go oh great there's
something that I can work on there's
something that I may be lacking that I
needed to be better at and that I found
is like just classic dramatic narrative
structure like the art of dramatic
writing that's what I've been doing you
know for the past six months or two a
year is just really nailing that aspect
you know cuz I can do visuals I can work
with actors I can do this I can do that
but like really getting those
fundamental tenants of storytelling is
is very important at least for me and
without those reviews that were negative
you know how do you learn you know
because I wouldn't have if everybody
would have gone oh this is great keep it
up don't change you don't learn anything
from that and I want to keep getting
better so the fact that there were
criticisms levelled at me it's like
thank you now I can make the next one
even better because I don't want to be
treading water like I need the next one
to be better and the latest short I did
I can say with certainty that it is
better than the feature that I did you
know and the feature I still think is
very good but the fact that I can do a
new project and for myself know that
there's a benchmark of getting better
that's you know that's paramount
importance to me
you